HBO's The Last of Us surprise fans of
the game with a radically different
start to the story in episode 1 but it
was almost something else entirely
here's why the showrunners decided to
change course the last of us has largely
sat in a ruined world where Humanity has
been utterly devastated by a rampant
fungal infection that transforms the
infected into aggressive hosts who
single-mindedly spread their sickness
zombie style
viruses can make us ill but fungi can
alter our very Minds the first episode
starts off with a dick cavett-like talk
show set in 1968 in which two
epidemiologists are having a discussion
one of the scientists mentions cordyceps
a real-life parasitic fungus that preys
on ants
fungus starts to direct the ant's
Behavior telling it where to go what to
do like a puppeteer with a marionette he
adds that although cordyceps cannot
currently survive in the human body it
may be able to eventually if the world
gets warmer and the fungi evolve
so if that happens
we lose
on HBO's official The Last of Us podcast
series creators Craig Mason and Neil
druckman explain that several intro
pictures were considered including one
that took its inspiration from a popular
documentary series Mason explained on
BBC's planet Earth you can watch this
beautiful demonstration of how cordyceps
Works how it takes over an ant it's
quite horrifying and it tells you
everything you need to know so what we
had decided to do was make our own
little video like that amazing said that
although the information presented was
pertinent and interesting it wasn't
necessarily good TV as it was more of an
intellectual argument druckman then
quipped that this intro was in fact a
snoozefest
you're being kind it was kind of boring
Mason agreed then added it was a little
boring to watch it was a little bit like
oh in social studies class I had written
this thing early as if I'd found a
transcript of an old Dick Cavett from
1969. I remember showing it to Neil and
he was like this is a little weird but
druckman ultimately came around to the
idea and nearly at the last minute Mason
said we're about three to four weeks
away from rapping and I'm like dude I am
not thrilled with this original opening
so I sent the new one to him again and
this time he was like oh
seeing the final version seeing it
edited I loved it
Mason then said that both himself and
drugman agreed that the talk show
opening was far more effective because
the information was dramatized and not
so clinical and it nearly laid the
groundwork for the rest of the series
Mason said these like quotes unquote
Monday moments with the Miller family
and this talk show intro elevated all
those scenes because now because of that
opening there's a tension that's just
like hanging in the air everything
became more tense and more captivating
because of this opening and there are no
treatments for this no preventatives no
cures they don't exist it's not even
possible to make them The Last of Us
currently has a 99 critic score and 96
audience score on Rotten Tomatoes for
the first episode as of the making of
this video so it appears they made the
right call
[Music]